je mène l enquête dans les coulisses et
fait au moins deux heures pourquoi fut
recherche invité mystère pas essayer non
c'est pas la bonne émission
1 2 3
bravo très jolie voix j'adore bosser
comme à son habitude véronica antonelli
chanteuse mary qui livré une performance
devant le sacré que quand soudain quatre
policiers viennent interrompre sa
représentation pour tapage diurne de ses
bases ça arrive c'est bien une scène
largement relayé sur les réseaux sociaux
trois semaines après les faits la
chanteuse n'en revient toujours pas
c'est la première fois de ma vie
qu'une telle chose arrive
[Musique]
pareil après
j'étais viré genevois
[Applaudissements]
lors de l'interpellation la cantatrice
n'a pas l'autorisation préfectorale
nécessaire elle affirme néanmoins être
connus de la mairie elle qui assure des
visites touristiques chanter dans le
quartier
mais c'est bien pour nuisances sonores
que cet artiste a reçu une amende de 68
euros
[Musique]
tata yoyo
ok il ya
les rita
[Musique]
jean
numéro 11 bryan avec jul ils partagent
la même passion le tout une
non
[Musique]
marco fontana
médiateur rangs de l'aja
on perd du temps là
et rien là dedans
or c'est c'est pas grave
médiateur
[Musique]
alors voilà je crois que ça marche merci
à toute l'équipe technique au sont
désolés véritablement pour cette culture
c'est vrai que la journée a été
compliquée
avec des intempéries terrible
c'est plus efficace de remplir le
réservoir des deux côtés en même temps
un plein de diesel qui ne lui coûte pas
trop cher
190 dollars seulement pour 2 115 litres
deux fois moins qu'en france
à ce prix là la clim peut tourner 24
heures sur 24 dans un camping car tout
fonctionne sur batterie et pour durer le
plus longtemps possible
elle fonctionne en 12 volts résultat le
couple a dû s'équiper entièrement d'un
électroménager adapté qui ne tient pas
toujours ses promesses safar passer ça
je ferai pas de chemise avec ça s'est
passé trop seuls besoins de barbie
j'étais qu'annuler dernière
les voyages pas franchement écologique
mais pas de quoi faire culpabiliser
michel et robert
est ce que ça contribue au dérèglement
climatique sans doute dans une certaine
mesure mais les trains aussi et selon
certains hommes politiques
même les pets de vache sont plaints de
méthane
[Musique]
oh
et
toi je te jure quoi ça va mal finir
ses lagons mains du groupe omc et
surtout
bouge
beaucoup d'amour
[Musique]
manger quand elle rigole c'est mauvais
signe